attention cette vidéo s'adresse vraiment
aux abonnés de la chaîne à ceux qui
suivent la chaîne qui aiment ça et pas
qui regarde forcément une vidéo de temps
en temps ça risque de pas vous
intéresser je vous le dis tout de suite
pour pas que vous soyez déçu c'est
vraiment une vidéo qui en relation avec
la chaîne et l'avenir de la chaîne
marre de rire production présente salut
nous sommes samedi soir quoi mais non
c'est pas vrai on est dimanche
oui mais je fais cette vidéo samedi soir
parce que ce soir je joue sur la péniche
le nez rouge en spectacle et je vais
pouvoir puisque depuis le mois d'octobre
c'est complet donc j'imagine que vous
êtes nombreux et j'ai peur de pas avoir
le temps de faire la vidéo de la montée
pour la mettre à l'heure pour
aujourd'hui un diablo heures je sais ça
fait bien longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu
dans un vidéo toi exactement ça y est je
suis cuit et les boutons bateau ça je
crois que la première fois que je chante
un peu juste en impro et tu fais diablo
du cash mais complice ou promènent
rideau je remets le rideau et encore je
remets le rideau évite de dire qu'il ya
des complices devant la caméra par
contre d'accord mon vieux complice mon
vieux or si toi aussi tu as compris
cette vanne fait un hashtag je suis
choqué dans les commentaires là je vous
fais voir ce qu'on appelle la conduite
du spectacle donc on va commencer par un
numéro où je met quelqu'un au sol est
gelé écrase le sternum
ensuite je le mets sous hypnose et je
mets des choses comme ça dans sa bouche
si c'est une fille plutôt mignonne bon
je deviens un petit peu plus
entreprenants quoi la suite du numéro
c'est de regarder si le public reste
quand même dans la salle ou pas
et s'il ya des témoins ou pas si les
gens sont partis pour qu'ils aient plus
du tout de témoin après je brise la
nuque un classique
il me reste plus que 13 vidéos à faire
pour terminer le défi que mme été lancés
cette année faire une vidéo par jour
depuis 1er janvier au 31 décembre les
366 vidéo je les ai presque atteinte
ça fait bizarre en fait d'arriver à ce
stade là et je travaille depuis un petit
moment sur comment ça va se passer les
prochaines qu'est ce que je vais faire
je vous annoncerai tout ça de début
janvier mais c'est là où j'ai besoin de
vous j'aimerais dans les commentaires de
cette vidéo que vous me disiez ce que
vous aimeriez en termes de périodicité
une tous les jours une par heure vous
décidez tout est possible vraiment le
rythme idéal que vous aimeriez est ce
qu'il ya des séries particulière que
vous aimeriez des sujets des formes
différentes puisque je pense sans trop
vous en dévoiler que je vais garder des
vidéos un petit peu qui ressemble au
mental blog mais je vais m'ouvrir aussi
à d'autres styles de vidéos et à
d'autres séries peut-être que vous aussi
vous avez des idées genre me donner un
défi à réaliser je le réalise
puisqu'on sera plus sur le rythme d'une
par jour c'est plus envisageable parce
qu'au final je vais pas passer moins de
temps sur la vidéo ça va prendre autant
de temps qu'avant mais j'aurais plus le
temps de préparer des choses de les
faire et de faire des plus gros montage
vous pouvez me dire les thèmes que vous
aimeriez que j'aborde vous pourrez me
dire la périodicité hockey le style de
série le style de vidéos
je vous avais déjà posé une question
pour savoir si est-ce que j'ouvrais une
chaîne secondaire ou pas pour faire les
blogs que j'avais envie de faire
la plupart des réponses ont été non donc
je n'ouvrirai pas je vous bien pour ça
que vous pose les questions et il ya une
majorité de personnes
et ça c'est plutôt drôle qui disait moi
j'aime pas les blogs je déteste ça
n'ouvre pas de chaîne secondaire et je
trouve ça marrant parce que c'est des
gens qui n'aiment pas le blog mais qui
préfère quand même que je les laisse sur
la chaîne est ce que je peux comprendre
soi mais c'était drôle de dire non
j'aime pas m'aimer le quand même sur
cette chaîne là et pas sur une autre
donc pour ce qui les blogs j'ai déjà une
idée de comment ça va se passer
il y en aura très peu il y en aura une
dizaine dans l'année mais d'une manière
un peu particulière
bref vous avez compris l'idée c'est une
vidéo mentale blog vraiment spécial pour
le coup puisque je vous pose simplement
la question qu'est ce que vous aimeriez
vous voir l'année prochaine qu'est-ce
qui vous ferez tripes et qu'est ce qui
fait que vous trouveriez encore un
intérêt à regarder cette chaîne
moi je vais continuer à travailler
dessus et je pense le 2 janvier je vous
ferai une vidéo pour vous dire comment
va se passer l'année quels sont les
défis que je vais essayer de relever
quelle va être la forme la périodicité
externe alors je sais que j'aurais pu
faire un sondage directement sur youtube
ou un google forme mais je vois bien que
quand je fais ça il ya moins de
personnes qui participent donc mettez
tout dans les commentaires
je vais référence et tout ça et je me
m'embêterait mois remettre tout dans un
tableau excel afin de voir un peu ce qui
s'en dégage mais ne vous dites pas que
votre avis importe peu il importe
vraiment donc peu importe que ça a été
déjà dit mille fois ou pas du tout dans
les commentaires ou que vous pensiez que
ce soit une idée ridicule mettez moi
tout ce qui vous concerne vous c'est
important pour moi de continuer à lire
les commentaires et là c'est important
pour moi d'avoir vos avis
individuellement vraiment un par un et
pas un truc de masse selon un sondage de
masse je crois que j'ai tout dit au
moment où vous regardez cette vidéo je
serais déjà levé oui je suis triste que
le défi s'arrête et regarde je suis
content de récupérer un peu plus de
sommeil hâte de lire vos réponses il
concept de vous demander votre avis vous
plaît pensez à liker et à vous abonner
et rendez vous demain 17h ciao
bah oui pour ceux qui sont encore là
j'ai commencé à recevoir les lettres
pour le jeu des 200 cas il y en a déjà
cinq mille de reçus j'ai pas encore tout
ouvert j'ai pas encore tous triés parce
que j'essaye de retrouver mon vrai
courrier à l'intérieur ce que tout
arrive à de la boîte postale où vous
avez envoyé donc j'entends faire le tri
je commence elle les envoie qu'à la fin
du mois
ne vous inquiétez pas
[Musique]